[Music]
anonymous sourcing was an issue in
BuzzFeed story about Michael Kohn saying
he was directed to lie to Congress they
you know the the story as I recall was
sourced to two people who were involved
in an investigation of Trump Tower
Moscow but we don't know who they are we
have to suspend disbelief and believe
the reporters and decide whether
BuzzFeed news and those reporters have
our confidence and enjoy a high level of
credibility I actually after for
merchants of truth looking so deeply at
BuzzFeed news thinks that they are
careful they have 20 investigative
reporters some quite experienced they
have great investigative editors you
know I think that that BuzzFeed news
does deserve trust Ben Smith the editor
of BuzzFeed has made it clear that the
two reporters Jason Leopold and Anthony
Cormier had worked on the story for
months and then they finally got hard
confirmation from two sources that they
were very confident and so you know I'm
not sure that a rush was one of the
contributors to what happened there and
frankly I'm holding my breath hoping
that BuzzFeed is able as soon as
possible to show that its story was true
anonymous sources proliferate all over
the news landscape when I was at the
Times my predecessor as executive editor
went on a campaign to cut down on them
but I'll give you a big reason why it's
so difficult to do so because many of
the stories where you must
commonly see a not anonymous sources our
Washington stories and Presidents Bush W
and Obama initiated eight separate leak
investigations these were unheard of in
an earlier period and that meant the
sources could be prosecuted for leaking
classified information and you know they
were left with jail time in some cases
and huge legal bills so that put a deep
freeze on sourcing in Washington and
people's willingness to put their name
behind the information that they're
giving but information has so much more
credibility when it is attached to a
name source it just does
The Times actually succeeded in cutting
down on them for a while but to get
crucial information before the public
some anonymous sourcing is just
necessary and news organizations have
all different standards for when use of
an unknown AMA source is allowed and in
the case of The Times a senior editor
must know the identity of the source
[Music]
you